to make the preferences appear on the
phone we need to modify settings
activity in the oncreate method we're
going to replace this to do with some
code we're going to call add preferences
from resource with the pref underscore
general xml that we defined then we need
to bind the preference summary to the
value of the location preference this
means that when the user changes the
preference the summary value underneath
the label will be updated if you look at
the Declaration of this method we see
that for a given preference it sets a
preference change listener on it if you
scroll to the top you see that the
settings activity actually implements
the interface on preference change
listener that method is found down below
where we override the on preference
change method remember that our location
preference is actually an edit text
preference so it won't fall into this
case but it will fall in this case down
here then in the settings UI you can see
that the summary is now this value make
these changes in your app see the
instructor notes for the lines of code
you need